[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about my life be mess I
can't we can't help that all it takes
yes is shaking that's all the tapes in
the legends links of cities around
[Applause]
thanks for having me back thanks for
waking up yeah does your puppy my puppy
is good already lost the record right
now yeah I was expecting a Red Dead
Redemption and it's fun yeah playing
what is that it's like you know the
makers of grand theft auto yes yeah oh
my god it's like it's like Grand Theft
Auto but to watch you're a cowboy oh
[ __ ] dude it's that Rockstar Games you
could fish there's game you could play
Domino's you could gamble there's what's
so funny
thanks Evie do whatever you want funny
about the way people describe this game
it's basically somebody saying that I'm
not gonna live regular life but I'm a
little regular life through this game
and exactly like how you just started
off is I could rob banks but would you
start with I can play Domino's in the
game you know what's crazy you have to
eat in this game like you have to eat
every like hour you have to like eat
crackers or cook meat oh that's dope so
it's like real life pleasing to me
you can even you could even improve the
me like it fits uh have you ever played
the UFC game yeah that's fine too
so we're on I like creating my own
character though so we're at a retreat
we're playing at UFC game no I don't
even know what's called only play games
okay what I liked about it is unlike
Street Fighter where it's just a life
bar that was like what in 1997 what's
the last like fighting him and there's
also a stamina bar so as you're beating
the [ __ ] out of someone your stamina is
also going down as if it's like in real
life I love it so just because you're
being the cop out of something someone
can't all knock you out still could just
amylose yeah just like in real life Red
Dead has stabbed that's funny brought
that up cuz in Red Dead there's um your
health
circle stamina and your dead I circle
that's why you gotta feed on and so Dead
Eye is you know what you could do you
you're like a superhero you could slow
down slow down
tiny Oh so you press and Left stick
right stick and then it goes but all
these things have been done darling
oh okay boom man was the first time you
go poopoo boom and he'll just do it all
at one time yeah you feel so it makes
you feel so good they did that for the
first Red Dead though yeah I know yeah
it's it's dope that's dope
yeah it's crazy like rockstar games wait
can you get fat too from overeating I
think so yeah I haven't done that
because I barely eat I could barely eat
I like hunter can you like beat your
children in that game
no but you kid down I'll services come
and take you away I think you can't play
the game for three years but there is
karma no but if you were to do that
there's caramel involved so if you do
anything bad there's like a red like
cowboy picture that shows up but if you
go if you like help like I had a suck
poison out of this um black eyes leg a
big dick I'm sorry no no because um he
got he got he got fire us
poisonous snake you got bit by a
cobrados dick and you're like it I'll be
a good Samaritan
yeah way up especially back in the day
because everybody was so racist was like
way up there
well I sucked it out all right you suck
the poison out of this yeah did you the
dialogue was like don't tell anybody
because here the black guy you know
don't because it's embarrassing cuz
we're two dudes but um yeah so when I
did that's a nice act to do wouldn't you
say you're not even supposed to suck
poison and plus I'm assuming B so that's
a good you know there's karma I'm
assuming because it's cowboy days ends
back in the day I'm suing like things
are like accurately racist too so yeah
there's KKK yeah that's what I'm doing
assuming because you helped like a black
person back in the day it's like one
time I was just riding my horse and then
I seen these two guys by swamp and they
they had a lock they had like this safe
and they go oh we're gonna be there [ __ ]
did Chinese people with laundromats know
I don't know I haven't bumped into him
yeah there's Chinese people on the first
one okay yeah like there's this one
Chinese guy you could do these side
missions and there's this one Chinese
guy with a broken like cart and then he
has a Chinese accent yeah yeah yeah but
so I peep them to finish I peep them out
and then once they finish doing and they
got the lock open that I robbed them I
got a gold bar yeah well you know I'll
take a loss for a gold bar I'll take
I'll take one bad mine I'll take it -
for a row this seems like a half-built
railroad and a Chinese person just
looking at hello like Oh that'd be so
dope dude with the overall and the sit
on his face I'll pick him up bring him
to my camp in heaven little and you're
like one of us do you think you can do
it in real life like act it out what do
you think that you're doing in this game
act it out like real life like go to
like a Western thing and what do they
call the though it goes Camelot places
right yeah yeah what do they call real
life
like medieval times but that site Sheol
basically red when what I've seen from
Red Dead Redemption is a literally West
world and you get to play West world
that's what
what is this world is it way better a
pitch then I get to go in the game and
cook food and tie my shoelaces it's just
like everybody's pitches like that and
it cracks me the [ __ ] up you know what
happened he can't you get sucked in Joe
every time a rockstar game comes out if
I do get it I'm gone for week for a week
December well we have our time off I'm
trying to get my [ __ ] done this is how
I've been doing it guys
I work on a reward system so I can't
play the game until I get something
productive done and what is that usually
well last night I was working on I'm
working on music so I'm doing a promo
thing with my cover and I'm trying to
learn how to use editing software yeah
and put music to like this post I'm
trying I'm working on so I was like I
spent two hours learning you know like
um how do you know use this editing
software and you know and then I did
something so I go you know what I feel
good I did this I made something I
deserve to play so you don't got to
finish it
you don't got to finish you just have to
do this I have to do something for I
can't play two hours at a time
that's productive I'm like avatar dude
like I I got a [ __ ] transfer myself
into the into the character and I live
in that world for a whole [ __ ] until
it's done until it's done I'm obsessed
like in my head I'm like now I gotta
finish that mission right now I can't
even think about anything else you get
that obsessed yeah you're like my
brother did we're playing on the
Nintendo switch to the overcook thing
you got that's a good that's a good game
no it is yeah yeah yeah yeah but I love
how strategic you read though too
because it would be playing this thing
and it's like you have to play with
everyone that's playing like you have to
do teamwork okay you go do this you
could it's so dog Thanksgiving it wasn't
it it's like a synchronicity you have to
be synchronized it's it's a
quick-thinking game where you have to
like prepare food it's like all of us
work in a kitchen I like deliver dishes
on time
more types done that's it's like yeah
the brain has to be like like really
then a teamwork makes the dream work
yeah like after every time that we would
fail that mission all right guys this is
what we got yeah yeah yeah this and this
and then you could do that and I know
what happened when the recent GTA came
out what what when it came out and never
Michael the the Los Santos the the most
recent one with Jonah Hill and all those
yeah so like that one I didn't speak for
48 hours
I played the game for 48 hours I stopped
just to eat and pee and then I went to
sleep but I put a timer on just so I
could sleep for like four or five hours
and I said I'm not gonna wake up I mean
I'm not gonna oversleep right I put the
alarm on so I could wake up in four
hours to continue the game and I beat
that [ __ ] game in three days cuz I
want you guys to keep the channel going
yeah don't get it that's why but I know
man
you know what I did though I'm just
letting you know it's not that good
right you know what I did though was I
got to see a timeline a timeline of the
story POW was a 17 minute breakdown on
YouTube yeah why'd you do that I don't
know now I want the game boy do I hate
let me just a piece of advice don't look
at anything red dead oriented then cuz
gonna [ __ ] it up it's gonna want is
there anything you see you're gonna be
like oh I didn't understand the concept
of looking at a game and saying I have
to play them like I can't wrap my head
around that it's like because I couldn't
specifically it's for me it's the
Rockstar brand and the content that they
produce so it's almost like my favorite
production company and director mmm cuz
then their stories are [ __ ] good and
then the gameplay just gets better and
better
it's like you see something you have to
eat it cuz that's how I really I might
if I saw like an ad for something yeah
and this will bit into some [ __ ] he has
crunched like a [ __ ] all night
yeah [ __ ] I eat that [ __ ] well can I
tell you what event there's random
events so you could cook in the game and
set up your camp right so you can either
craft something you can make um you can
see the game you can even take your
knife and do split bullet like you know
like like take your knife and then go
like that like cut the bullet in like a
like a like a plus yeah to make it to
split up your bullet like toast oh yeah
I like split split bullets like you
could do that cook meat you could sleep
right you can bake you can create
potions yeah you know and stuff like
that but so I'm by this trapper like a
trapper as a person that buys like um
like animal fur and and meats and stuff
so so my thought was okay I'm gonna camp
right by the trappers see cuz I could
hunt and skin them and then go right to
the trapper and slinging my stuff so
okay so it's at night time I don't know
where I'm at and when you're on that
screen where you're setting up your camp
nothing could happen you're like in this
other screen where you're just chillin
by the fire but something happened two
dudes entered my that screen goes hey
buddy do you mind if I warm up by a fire
sir oh they're trying to steal and then
so the guy goes like this warms up his
hands and then his homey comes by and
she has his gun pointed at my head
what do you do I was like trying to do
something in there it couldn't do
anything but they go what are the
Murphree brutal boys now you know
partner this is a warming and then they
walked off oh they were just messing
with you or messing with me steal from
you they were messing with me but
they're but they're a gang that have you
seen on what's that movie word
deliverance they're like the country
folk up in the mountain also you got a
hillbilly
you're like the hillbillies yeah I'm
trying to go to them and [ __ ] them up
no I'm enemies what they know about me
now so now anytime I'm around that
region you got to go 500 wives that [ __ ]
them circle oh that's dope that's just
like GTA yeah where they know cuz I was
trying to ride my horse cuz there's a
certain a plant called Yoli and or plant
where if I this place all you're doing a
Joe right now your
come on grab this plant I could create
poison arrows you think so you have to
go through their territory go through
their territory so I was riding my horse
and I see this wagon with dynamite
they're trying to from the hill like
explode my horse they go I told you boy
and then there's like 20 of them like
chasing oh [ __ ] but so these guys are
from the 1700s they settled in that area
in the 1700s they were like I don't know
they work somewhere but then now they
working the caves and then I called the
Murphree brood boys see I only like
games if I can get like a game genie
type of [ __ ] and then make sure I never
die because what I would do in that game
is if I could get that hat coat I would
go up and I will [ __ ] murder every
single one of them and as we lie up with
the horse and the horse is [ __ ]
[ __ ] on them understand and I feel
the same way too but they're pretty
they're pretty deep dude and they keep
regenerating I bet they keep regenerate
and they keep coming I want to do that
too I don't like them either
cuz I'm just trying to do the right now
trying to hunt sell my fur to the
trapper because I would I would take my
seed and I would [ __ ] plant it in
every single Murphy woman that they will
do nothing about it to be honestly
there's this men I will plant my seed in
them as well
pregnant all them pregnant every single
one of you I'm sorry for you talking
about I'm sure that doesn't help like
that makes you one did you go back to uh
back home so your parents for
Thanksgiving or do you see it no I went
down to San Diego I have a cousin um
down that's right Arizona and alright
yeah my folks are in Gilbert yeah but
not when Tommy kalila
blob went down to San Diego to visit our
cousins Jenny and Eddie and Katherine
I don't know you guys had a family here
I thought they were all up it's I don't
even know like my cousin Catherine has
three kids and I met him for the first
time in there like dude one who plays
baseball for ASU like scholars they're
like athletes yeah family dude I know I
know it's a weird place is that one the
best Thanksgiving you were like playing
ping pong upstairs that athletic family
that's tight on their side yeah I mean
you know Bobby wrestles you though yeah
but then we got into drugs yeah it's
like in you guys though cause like if
you look at the lineage of my family is
nothing but people who knit like mittens
nothing they can't even do the
individual fingers yeah you gotta give
your family more credit than that I
refuse I'm fighting against genetics
right now dude that's what I'm doing
dude no but no there's talent in there I
mean yeah but it's not it's not physical
talent though you're acting in goop dude
come on
thanks man but there's no physical town
is what I'm saying like watch goukan
theatres watch games anymore you're
great in that movie dude I say like
everybody that you said that like
collegiate athletes and stuff I don't
have any of that in my family I like how
he keeps changing topics I'm trying to
compliment his that easy well you
stopped by your family I'm talking about
your family
dude I saw my uncle I hadn't seen in 20
years
oh my dad's brother why they be my dad's
brother yeah they've been beefing no no
no it's okay this is what happened like
this personal what else I'll talk about
it my dad has had eight strokes he's
angry huh that's not is it is it
recently you have really pretty hands
what the [ __ ] dude that should threw me
off man no way like I had model like leg
legit well you said eight dude I [ __ ]
got a chub like can you get it again do
it
do look at radius [ __ ] hands I've
ever seen Wow
which man very nice but I bite them my
appointment so you're very the movement
to your very elegant it looks very
slender and smooth you have the hands of
a 13 year old girl okay oh brother
well no that's because okay like Korean
I don't know if it's with this is how it
is with your family but like in like a
tragic event happens they kind of like
keep their distance
you know but they keep their distance
but they they they ask over the phone or
like Izzy okay but they kind of give us
because they don't want you use our
space they gave my family their space
you out yeah so no no they're not dude
that's like their home that's like his
brother only living room that's life is
both yeah like that's like you and your
brother yeah they're like tight but yeah
tok-san he's got on Parkinson's is it
eight strokes like recently know that he
okay so he's had minor ones but he's had
one or two gnarly ones did your dad come
back
he used to how'd you know come back
stroke cuz it's like used to he used to
back in the day that's crazy like creepy
people I I think there's like Asian
people in general don't but I know a lot
of like Korean males that I know I'm
just making up all kinds of words of
what you said met you
yeah met you and so like drinking and
drinking and smoking and high stress is
very Korean and so I've known a lot of
like people for example my dad just had
a stroke like a few months ago and
a few other smoker drink or two well
he's just angry old fun what some of
Koreans and strokes and then angry a lot
of my friends parents that I know like I
could name three people out the bed that
had a stroke too i'ma get one salty
foods smoking and drinking so high blood
pressure is like a huge Korean thing
that a lot of Asian people have it too
just because of our diet and an Asian
man yeah yeah this last way salty foods
and anger yeah so how do you how do you
reduce that like what what suggestions
do you have to the viewers into the
listener somebody give me a virus be
positive let's make some deposit drink
the detox I just feel like no no that's
good
no keep going on that axis meditate
healthy lifestyle you dope and you're
doing that you know what the funny thing
is like so when my parents came over
this way my dad sight how come you're
always angry all the time I'm like
listen I'm very happy it's just that
every time you get close to me I get
angry so it's like this my dad like you
know god bless his [ __ ] soul
they just say he is so [ __ ] bored out
of his [ __ ] mind now he doesn't know
when to stop talking so we're trying to
watch a [ __ ] movie together right I
want to bond with my dad I'm like oh
we're gonna watch a film we're just
gonna Korean movie Chinese come from
moving alright so that's the best
bonding every [ __ ] three minutes he's
making it no three seconds he's making a
joke sitting there making a joke and
then my uncle is doing the same thing
and so forth it's soaking all of them
are just talking talking throughout the
whole [ __ ] film and I'm just sitting
there just like quiet and like and my
mom is so mad she goes my mom literally
looks at my dad and says in Korean she
goes what are you gonna stop making
jokes that nobody's laughing it didn't
[ __ ] phase it dude that's amazing
keeps going up so I go yup and I just
get up three flights upstairs and my mom
comes in she goes you came up here cuz
you're mad at anybody and I was like she
goes you're mad cuz you're mad at your
dad right now I say yup I was like how
come he doesn't just stop talking why
does he just talk every [ __ ] 10
seconds how do you just stop talking and
she goes why do you think we fight all
the [ __ ] time dude she's gotta learn
how to blank him out so he doesn't know
when to stop talking she said you have
to learn how to blank him out but she
either that's what she's like once you
stop making jokes I was laughing at dr.
yeah it got to her cuz he just doesn't
stop like we're just chilling right this
is my dad like it would be like he'll
say something he doesn't understand
small talk small talk is a craft right
and you would think after 50 years of
living he would develop the skill that
he goes on to long [ __ ] rants long
rants or something that has nothing to
do dude you're getting mad right now
come on yeah it'll be like this like
we're just chilling having a good time
he goes you ever trim your nose hairs
dad what the [ __ ] is that hat that what
did you even say that right you have
nose hairs yeah no I don't but he just
says random [ __ ] and I'm like okay I'm
like no not really and he's going back
to it well you know nose hairs right and
I'm like to shut the [ __ ] up please just
means he's dumb like dumb like mine yeah
he's just socially so awkward dude like
I can't I can't stand it cuz my mom is
so good at it yeah my mom could talk to
anybody we have great conversations my
dad comes up with what about the nose
hairs you should do that too but not
like offensive like that he'd be like so
how are we with their balances yeah like
[ __ ] like that I mean it wouldn't piss
me off cuz I'm just like oh he just
doesn't know how to connect people you
know some like oh they're cool and then
I'll start the conversation I said my
daddy comes over he sees tycoon he's
like you don't love your son huh yeah
[ __ ] like that why he goes cuz his house
so long again Kyle yeah Wow I'm like or
if you rephrase things and if you're
like hey have you ever thought about
giving them a haircut yeah yeah there's
a way to say coming and then spending
first I know you don't love them no
matter what and you're up already you
know wait what the [ __ ] why what do you
mean I'm trying to be a good dad and
he's like you don't cut his hair and
they don't understand the concept of
like you had when somebody says let's
not talk about a subject they just want
to talk about just because they want to
talk about it oh yeah so for example
like my dad's like so what are you gonna
give Marielle ringing I was like hey I
told you about 30 times to stop asking
me that funny right and he goes by I
won't ask and all of a sudden 10 set 10
minutes later it'd be nice if you gave
Mariola ring right now I'm like you son
of a [ __ ] mother you know what my dad
would say who's my dad like asked like
when we're gonna get married or when
we're gonna have kids I might tell my
daughter hey can we not [ __ ] talk
about this anymore and then like 10
minutes later he'll bleh I wish
I wish we could talk about sort of
aggressive do you take it my skin's
crawling right now dude guys this whole
weekend me renewed you wanna Kitty mad
this whole weekend your face it's all
your face you want some [ __ ] you're
about to swear everybody left me in the
house my brother my cousin they all left
all of them where they go huh all these
brothers left they'd even see their pair
so I was stuck with his parents and my
parents oh [ __ ] no holy [ __ ] dude if you
if you you've been around if that you
know how we talked so we went to a
restaurant right I kid you not
especially when he's drunk yeah this is
how he talks so we said the restaurant
they go Oh today it's gonna be a lunch
buffet so we don't have like a regular
man he goes well why the hell not I
don't get embarrassed I start a fight
dude solution for you what CBD juice oh
I take CBD teacher if you drink
CBD I heard it calms you down oh it
doesn't work on me I know that though
like that parent raised a yeah yeah just
over the weekend man I was listening to
them speak to my cousin over Skype and
that alone it would they weren't even
talking to me okay it was [ __ ]
irritating me because they don't know
they don't be talking [ __ ] circles
yeah they don't know how to get to the
[ __ ] point yeah and it's like I'll
ask him one question I'll be like so
does this person want to sell you the
house or not well we're thinking that
this is what they're thinking and we're
thinking that you know it might be a
better idea I was like I didn't ask you
what you thought they're thinking and I
was going [ __ ] crazy dude you wasted
five minutes
talking to yourself about what you think
just tell me facts tell me facts please
we're done
[Music]
[Music]